[Music]
water is becoming an increasingly scarce
resource as droughts worsen across the
western united states the scorching
drought made worse by climate change is
draining reservoirs at an alarming pace
hotter temperatures and dry vegetation
the firefight is worsening
in california's central valley water
prices have risen as high as 2 thousand
dollars an acre foot an acre foot is a
unit of measurement that in this case is
the amount of water it takes to cover
one acre of land with one foot of water
so
one acre foot is the equivalent of about
326 000 gallons of water as a price
comparison in non-drought times water
can sell for 250 per acre foot on the
highest end
other farmers have sold their future
water rates for as high as 5 000 per
acre foot
two of the biggest players in the
california water scene are stuart and
linda resnick
they're the billionaire owners of the
wonderful company known for their
pistachios mandarin oranges and palm
wonderful pomegranate juice the resnicks
are also majority owners in the kern
water bank one of california's largest
underground water storage facilities
the resnicks right now are worth 8
billion dollars that's quite
conservative to be honest it's from
their farmland assets they have a lot of
different real estate a lot of other
personal assets but this water bank is
honestly pretty invaluable and it could
be one of their most valuable assets if
it ever really was up for sale
a water bank is an area mostly
underground where water can be stored
reliably until it is needed
from above water banks tend to look just
like big puddles but underneath they can
hold hundreds of thousands of gallons of
water
the where the current water bank is is
where the current river would peter out
so it is naturally an excellent uh
groundwater recharge area because over
the millennia you just you know it was
it was built up with sand and gravel and
you know all that good stuff rather than
clay which is hard to you know percolate
water through so it's it is naturally
the best place to recharge water i mean
it's almost incalculable to understand
how
valuable it is first of all hundreds of
acres
and second of all it is in the
crosshairs of the kern river the cross
valley canal and the california academy
so it has lots of ways to fill up
current groundwater bank continues to be
i think the absolute jewel of banking
and recharge in california bar none
to value a water bank we have to
multiply the going rate for an acre foot
of water times the full capacity of the
water bank which for kern water bank
is about 1.5 million acre feet but
prices right now during a drought are
much higher
at one thousand dollars an acre foot the
resnick stake would be worth about 850
million dollars
and at two thousand dollars per acre
foot their stake would be worth about
1.7 billion dollars
i've been asking around about prices and
people are getting really kind of cagey
about what what they're a paying for you
know water and b what they're trying to
sell it for because now it's getting
really desperate it's a lot of money
it's considered a public resource you
know who's making that money the public
gets annoyed and frustrated and outraged
when they start seeing you know that
kind of money going for what they
consider to be a public resource
we have a lot of very impoverished
communities
farm worker communities mostly hispanic
mostly spanish speaking many that have a
great deal of fear of dealing with you
know regulators of any kind because
they're not necessarily here uh with all
their documentation and so they live in
these communities where it's not just
contaminated water but they can't even
get water you know their wells are
breaking or their wells were drilled to
100 feet and now because of groundwater
extraction you know the water table is
down to 400 feet so
you have those situations that are going
on right now the drought is exacerbating
it
this world of california water is
absolutely insane on pretty much every
level
who owns it who moves it
how much
you can get for it what your rights are
what your constrictions are i mean it's
all different it's just a huge patchwork
of crazy
[Music]